hello and welcome to this video playing
Walter order by down we don't know yet
king's indian of' platform quite a
number of games but just the plus to
score oh ok the exchange variation it's
not very exciting ok this is slightly
slightly dodgy
Wow um yeah I know this is kind of a
theoretical line but I don't remember I
don't remember I don't recall Brooke
doesn't have minutes can't do that I
mean I'm sorry after I have to play at
some point 95 now
it looks pretty awkward I thought I
might get the bishop bag but doesn't
seem to be and that's what you get and
you play the qilin unit they play the
exchange variation against you
yeah just not very nice not a nice
position at all you can go night before
or something maybe bishops III here 9
before a three no hmm I cannot be stuck
in the trade some stuff here now one
pair of points is actually quite nice to
trade here to take and go 95 yeah maybe
this is not so bad I mean not
particularly happy of course but maybe
there were worth things worse things
that could have happened yeah
unfortunately 96 or something yeah I
don't want to trade down all the rooks
and really don't
no take only eight hmm chat else okay
so is there anything the night only six
is currently what is he doing here like
Age 3 or something anyway King up to g6
is my idea also getting rid of the
immediate back back and back rank issues
yeah probably was also worried about
neither form not sure if this was
something he had to worry about but I
think he felt it was a problem I'm
starting to like my position here not
like I'm better but at least I feel I'm
reasonably safe maybe I should have
played 95 immediately King g6 was a bit
of the that was was actually quite
stupid but between teen this move
so I can not do this I can play look a a
drug a true maybe try to enter yeah now
look here and if it trades I've got 94
at the end and tending 92 and I don't
shop c 59
and let's do this threatening 95 okay he
addressed that but now here you cannot
play rook h1 because I take actually 94
okay check now I'm winning stuff
threatening nighty too and night on b3
was hanging so I'm winning the g3 porn
and I think the game okay so should be
form is that winning or not is called f5
reaction twin check that opposite
colored bishops is a win with my king
near the two connected passes i get f 5
and so on
I can also go g3 immediately he has no
no big squares to go to g3 king you 1 it
doesn't matter I'm morning so do this
white resigns it's always tough against
Lee exchange variation out but who he
played this slide that you obviously
knew I know as he six is a slightly
risky line I'm pretty aware of that but
I didn't want to play the super boring
stuffy rook e8 equalizes for black but
it's very very very very boring this is
95 66 and so on black equalizers with
this but as I said it's very boring yeah
hmm taking is better Jack yeah this is
downright terrible so I have to do this
and then Bishop f6 itim upon down for no
compensation night is six and now he
just went this I think this is the
theoretical I'm are probably bishop is
success correct yeah this is probably
probably not good Jan as we have seen it
was it was kind of annoying here here
why does certain develop I think he
probably played a little bit too um a
little bit too lame in a way I got some
some stuff traded now the engine still
likes white with age three now he's
still better i felt i was even worse to
be honest check out this and now now he
started to do things that probably lot
led to led to problems before and here i
thought that you would do this I have
this but still okay this is actually
pretty nice him this is a pretty pretty
big square and then wants to check into
this gives one an advantage
yeah I probably still do to the bishops
so here now I and this was a mistake I
should have done this immediately I only
saw a little bit later again I should
that should do this immediately but he
never he never fought against it oh yeah
mr. would move 9704 night h5 no I didn't
see that one kind no I'm threatening
night c5 and roped it towards the
engines suggestion here here he has to
avoid Luke age one I think you gauge
wonders loose Chang engine doesn't agree
because it thinks that it can give the
b3 porn ok ok the b3 phone is definitely
i'm the better pawn to give away and g3
pawn and we saw was pretty and pretty
awful this is the engines line and only
a slight advantage for black yeah that's
possible maybe he can draw this yeah
maybe you can draw this and hear the jam
this ending is lost hmm yeah so he
missed a couple of good opportunities
there the exchange variation and said
it's not particularly exciting with it
is something that white players
shouldn't yeah completely underestimate
because it's at least something that is
very safe and it has some some poise and
especially if black is ambitious and
lucky i have played a somewhat risky
variation to avoid the total gather the
total simplification and then you
actually get shots 22 to win with white
ok well thanks for watching